foreign
foreign
foreign
guys I regret to unfortunately inform
you this is clickbait you know I'll
leave the no I'm just playing bro
I'll leave you there bro
yes I'm here but
I don't know what does that say
it says Imaging Edge webcam well well
enough what does that mean
because I'm not really sure bro
because I usually go on through here I
don't usually have problems but
I don't know why it's saying that do you
have do you have a tech support guy
so this is very I think I can join it on
my phone if I'm not mistake
but the thing yeah let me let me try
again give me guys give me just one
minute because yeah no worries bro I've
tried before live
okay give me one second let me try it
again I don't know why it's doing that
sure for sure bro okay
but anyways aside from that guys how's
everything going for you on uh on a
Tuesday hope everything is well on her
bro how you doing
bro
how about you I'm the love bro doing
well doing well alhamdulillah
what does that say Buzzy bud is this
live dog no dog pre-recorded it's a
pre-recorded Flex we're just going back
in time and addressing it oh there you
go masha'allah
oh sorry you know what it was it was um
I think we used our cameras before uh
for a live appeal and I think it was a
setting Candlelight they need a tech guy
I just sorry
how are you doing bro I like the new
setup
yeah it is I I had to wait for these
Neon Lights the the bitter truth let me
let me let me change the view like this
bro so everyone can see those lights
Marshall yeah I like that you need some
fire in your life you know what I'm
saying there we go there we go martial
art all right guys so with that being
said we uh we wanted to start you know
12 p.m Standard Time 5 p.m Standard time
for the UK that's 12 45 p.m Ali that was
Standard time but it's all good we still
made it oh which lighting looks better
yeah this one oh
this one
so this one or turn off
this one this one I like this one
my my wife my wife is the sound lighting
and no jacket
you know what I mean all right bro
listen before we go right into it man
what's going on with the marriage
documentary man been a year since we
last spoke
yeah you know um to be honest it's it's
it's I realize it's it's such a massive
production bro we're doing we're working
with because we turned into a docky
drama so what that means is um the
things that I went through in my life
Etc sometimes you know when you watch a
documentary like you know a plane crash
oh yeah this will happen and then they
have the reenactment scene of what
happened
um we've turned into a docky drama so
there's real life footage and then
there's um reenactment scenes so because
of that obviously it's it's very hard
with this kind of stuff bro I mean on
this and on this level this is like very
very minimal level here you are looking
from anywhere from 30 to 60 000 pounds
to be spent on it so obviously I'm using
my own money but I'm also trying to find
sponsors because at the end of the day
it requires a lot and there's we've
turned it into seasons and episodes
because it's so big it can't be like oh
because there's so many lessons to be
learned so because of that we've done um
part one two three and four will be done
in a couple of months inshallah the
reason we're doing that is because so
once we release it there's not much
delay for the part two and three to four
to come out but we're recording in 4k
because that's what the production team
said said what that means is when you um
record a discussion so let's say I had a
discussion for like 45 minutes with
someone usually that's about what three
three and a half four gigabytes maybe it
depends on what if you're recording
1080. so if because we're recording 4K
Raw a 45 minute discussion is nearly one
terabyte meaning that's nearly 1 000
gigabyte so just imagine that I had to
buy extra space like a Google Drive 10
terabyte yeah I've got three eight
terabyte drives and we've got two teams
which have some of the footages then we
have a backup footage so if that gets
lost we have it so it's massive
production so the thing is it is coming
out because I've seen it with my own
eyes I'm like wow that's a documentary
so I've seen it it's there uh but
inshallah soon
um I'm not gonna give it time because
every time I'll give it time something
comes up but it's we're working on it
but inshallah it is an episode so it'll
be episode one and then two and then
three and then four that'll be season
one now from there we'll move on to a
different chapter of my life but yeah
it's looking good it's looking
interesting it's looking different and
it to the Muslim scene when it comes to
marriage that there's a whole
documentary dedicated to it and talking
about my personal life stories Etc
um and yeah it's it's interesting it's
interesting and I think a lot of lessons
will be learned a lot of lessons I
learned myself I genuinely believe that
Allah put me through all of that pain
and suffering good and bad times but
there was a happy ending and there was
an issue happening there was there so it
was very interesting where Allah
nurtured me and it puted me through this
and that and making me learn some really
important life lessons which I really
want to share with people otherwise I'll
be honest with you bro it took so long I
was thinking of canceling it I actually
thought maybe Allah doesn't want it to
come out and I said well if you don't
want it to come out I'll cancel it to me
I don't care what people think I'm not
doing it for the people I don't care oh
you made this way it's not coming it's
not coming I'm so sorry I tried but
every time
I was like you know what I don't think
Allah wants this to come out every time
someone will come like if I'm let's say
for example I don't have a camera guy
argument say something happened
somebody will come out of nowhere I'll
be like oh I'll sort that out for you
and then we'll do it and then things
will flop and I'll be like no no I don't
think Allah wants to come out and then
I'll use the heart again and then from
nowhere bro boom and we have the same
issue I found a camera guy we found
everything's on track here and brother
jabbie may Allah bless him if he's
watching this play the important role
and then we had editing issues because
you can be camera you can start with
films but editing might not be your area
I'm trying to say which it can be so
then I was stuck again because we had
the footage everything done within off
we've done our first episode of the
acting scene where we got some
characters you'll find out inshallah and
then once we've done that then I got
stuck with the um editor and then I was
in again like
what's going on so then I was like hola
Give Me A Sign and bro
my cameraman he lives in Peckham yeah so
I would have to try food 45 minutes to
50 minutes because I have to sit there
while the editing I have to be like oh
yeah so that was long it was also he had
other things to do so I made a Dua and a
brother who approached me four years ago
he was just saying you know if you need
filming Etc
he comes randomly comes back into my
life via something else and the guy
lives 10 minutes away from my house
and he is an amazing editor as well as
my brother jabby as well but the guy is
a brilliant editor so when that happened
I was like like is is this Allah saying
look I want it to come out but just wait
so we I know it's like when they will
seeking marriage I don't know if your
brothers are married are you guys
married yeah you're married
you married there
I was gonna say you have to be my
boyfriend my handsome Brothers how could
you not be married
so um anyway what was I saying I even
forgot what I'm saying so the point is
that subhanallah oh yeah that was saying
when I was getting to know the marriage
seeking process it was very similar to
the marriage documentary coming out you
might find it funny yeah you have these
ups and downs and you're like oh it's
not going to work out and then things
change and you lose hope and Allah
always sends like something and keeps
you going he always says something to
keep you going so in a nutshell to
answer your question which I turned into
a uh a uh big thing but it's basically
alhamdulillah I can see that Allah has
Allah wants it to come out inshallah so
I go sit with him every Thursday and
Friday and we just bang it out so just
go sit down bang mama what have you done
so it's going with him so inshallah
inshallah soon um once we've got all the
episodes one two three four ready then
we'll release one and then we'll
surprise for episode two
um and then from there on was inshallah
it will be and there's a theme for every
episode every episode teaches a lesson
this is what I learned from this mistake
that I did that's what I learned from
here this is what you should do red flag
I think it will genuinely help people
into the marriage seeking process and
even if you are married there's gems
there inshallah that you can learn that
would inshallah help you and maybe um
yeah I I think inshallah
so bro Baruch league for the very
succinct answer I did want to um address
what this comment said martial law
didn't know both the brothers I made not
only are we we both married Romney's
married too and for all the people
wondering where Rami is even Ali dollar
bro if you're wondering where Rami is he
uh had something come up and
unfortunately he couldn't be on the
stream inshallah he's gonna be on the
next one
um to all the people wondering if this
is live yes this is currently live
that's not pre-recorded
um so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
spend about just because we're a little
bit pressed on time about 30-ish minutes
kind of skim over some of the topics
um yeah brother Ali's take on in his
approach in his documentary how he's
going to tackle these topics
um and then if we are going to be making
more episodes we can go a little bit
more deeper into these topics and in the
end maybe we can do like a quick q a for
like 10-15 minutes so how
we're trying to cut it off by let's say
5 35 540 UK time sorry uh 640 UK time so
I'm gonna say the show's already
finished then
okay so um our time what time UK time
should be so should be another 40
minutes 40 to 45 minutes that's it
okay all right let's see yeah if we go
if we go over that is it possible I'm
not saying it might or not if we go over
that unfortunately it's not because I
got meetings and on house I'm in France
too so it's a little bit late
um but let's let's plan another time and
then we can definitely continue it no
okay Mr La so the first thing I would
ask you is you know throughout our life
we we have different perceptions on
different things as we grow older as we
mature we change our views on a lot of
things so the way it stands right now
with your current understanding of your
Islamic Paradigm and just in the real
world application of dealing with men
today what would your definition be of
masculinity
okay I think subhanallah if we look at
what the current trend is it really
[Music]
um
it it contradicts the Sunnah I believe
certain aspects not all of it
um and I think what it is is that we've
got this perception of um and I think
it's it's actually correlates with
actually my first episode of the
marriage documentary because in the
first episode of the marriage
documentary I go to my past and
knowledge is my path I go to when I was
very very young uh being a young man at
school and um they're being cool kids
Etc and all the girls are interested in
them and even though I used to my best
friend was one of the public kids Etc
um
that plays a massive role in a man's
thinking process how he thinks from a
very young age that's why we trauma
certain traumas that we have you look
back and it goes back it traces back to
something somewhere when he was young
and it doesn't leave you he actually
doesn't leave you I realize this when I
was I I was I just was exploring the um
I was being sitting with the
psychologist and always psychologists
usually they let you speak
him letting me speak it made me realize
certain things that I have traumas that
to this day affect my decision-making
processes so when we look at that at a
young age there's certain things that
impact men so for example being rejected
by the opposite gender like I'm talking
about Haram relationships I'm talking
about before I came to Islam so these
things have an impact on the way the man
thinks and then what happens is
sometimes men become bitter how and this
is one of the problems that we're having
is because they try to be the good guy
so they say good guys end up finishing
lost yeah so the point here is those
things have a trauma on the way men
perceive women so when they look at a
guy and he's masculine physically he's
strong he's I don't know six foot
something and there's certain
characteristics he has that that the
opposite his friend has or the this guy
has that he hasn't he doesn't have then
what happens is he's like okay those are
the things that I need so he starts to
think masculinity is that because that's
what women are attracted to if women are
attracted to that I want to be like that
so now they look at those traits they
can be physical traits which is okay
strong whatever it may be Etc but then
there are toxic elements to that which
is for example this guy might beat his
girlfriend up slap her he might Snapper
and he might be thinking okay this maybe
that's what girls like so do you see how
it starts oppose the Sunnah and now what
do men think they think okay
I need to move and behave in that manner
and become like that because it looks
like that's what girls like and then
they start following pursuing this idea
of being rude to girls or being a
certain way I mean look there is the
what is it the Jordan piece of course
the three dark uh traits
um that woman are usually attracted to
you know and that's why they usually say
for example a woman a woman tend to
um be more prone to fall for the
Stockholm syndrome which is that you
fall in love with the kidnapper men you
don't find that in men you find that a
woman so there's some conflation that
happens when they look at this and
thinking oh I need to be in this way on
or in that manner and I have to be uh
rough around the edges and and I'm like
not really I don't think so you know
being like for example I work there's
certain principles that are in my house
yeah okay and there's certain things
that I look for in my wife before I
married her
I have to pay for the rent I have to pay
for the shopping actually we just came
back from shopping that's why I'm late
you know because at the end of the day
that's the right of my wife I have to do
shopping I told you guys I'm going to be
late half an hour maybe that was I had a
little nap it went a bit overboard maybe
that's my fault I should have planned
it's not your guy's fault but the thing
is the shopping had to be done there has
to be food on the table that's my
responsibility bro I can't tell my wife
uh no no no that's my job I had to go
and do the shopping
um so I did the shopping there's certain
things I have to do electric gas bill
these are my responsibilities I would
say that is a part of my masculinity
I don't think that relationships would
work and this is how we talk about
gender roles if my wife was the provider
it wouldn't work now what do I mean but
it wouldn't work it's and people use
this phrase are you insecure you know
what's wrong with your wife working and
providing my wife can work if she wants
to a part-time job something for her own
she for example I can give her an
allowance which I have if she says you
know what I need a bit more and I want a
part-time job okay that's fine you can
do that that's that's your money the
money that you have Etc that's your
money you can do that but in a
relationship bro sometimes with our
partners you know men are physically
stronger women are mentally stronger
yeah okay and women can sometimes slice
you up with their words yeah she'll say
something and you're like man if someone
punched me in the face it wouldn't hurt
that much but the point is sometimes
these things happen so an argument and a
woman coming to her husband and saying
you know what I pay for the bills that
is a blow to a man
that no man would ever want coming home
and you know that you don't work and
your wife is a provider and then she
comes and tells you you know what who
pays for the rent
okay so the thing is to one man that
really really hurts him because number
one it might be in a situation if he's
lazy he's sibling he deserves that he
deserves I'll tell him he deserve that
straight right yeah however if you can't
find the job on top of that it is a
painful thing for a man he wants to be
the protector like Allah
men are the maintainers and protectors
that's our duty we love doing that if
I'm on a road and some guy's trying to
get rude to my wife I'm not going to
head out and go sort it out and let me
know when you're done I will do that and
I want to do it you get what I'm trying
to say and a woman feels what with the
nature she wants to be protected she
wants to be loved she wants to be
provided for you I'm trying to say I
understand the Dynamics have changed a
bit sisters might say well that's not I
understand what I'm saying generally
being masculine doesn't mean that and
just touch upon this if for example I
come home
and I'm tired yes obviously I'm gonna
bless my wife she does the best food and
I'm not just saying this I mean lasagna
cakes martial art she goes in yeah so
I'm very very happy I come home just
looking forward to uh so sometimes you
know what I might say you know what
she's she's working on she's looking
after the kids Etc you know what I'll
Hoover the house
no problem but obviously it's not my
description if I'm really tired I'll
come back from work you know my wife is
understanding but does that mean now I'm
emasculated if I come and I do the
Hoover for example let's say argument's
sake and arguments
no because even hijab himself we can
help our wives but the perception that
we have today is as if the masculine man
comes home and knocks the door bang bang
bang where's my food
get out here man this is not the
attitude this is not from the Sunnah and
we know the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him he helped he was a man involved
in his house bro he would do certain
things so are we going to judge
masculinity via the Sunnah are we going
to judge masculinity via Andrew Tate
because if we're going to do that we're
going to look at Abdullah Bin Masood who
was climbing a tree and his legs were
yeah and his legs were seen he said okay
because
he said if you knew in the sight of
Allah
his legs weigh more than Mount or as
much as
so now for a person who follows Andrew T
when he looks at Abdullah and he's going
to say
this man is not a real man that's what
they'll say I'm trying to say so where
do we measure it from and I believe the
Sunnah is the perfect combination of
what a real how a real man should be and
what real masculinity is about in a
nutshell
um
you know that reminds me of it reminds
me of the thing where when the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
um he would ask he had asked his uh wife
Aisha is it really low on her right I
really love Uncle which one is it that
you say for women okay
so he yes yes Aisha really low and yeah
it's like for food and she's like no
there's no food so instead of getting
upset he wears too fast
the okay no problem right here you know
it's like you don't see that today you
don't see that today people you have the
brothers out here getting upset and then
on my side of Islam too you have men who
just expect the women to just be doing
business and this
when it's like look I get it there
should be certain things that uh you
guys should talk about and they should
be like okay well here let's let's make
it this way but to fully expect this 100
of time from the woman like well the
woman's a human too
um
can I just re get lost some of the your
names I I got some names your name is
actually sorry hang him but just call me
Aki bro it doesn't matter okay okay now
come on I'm getting anger yeah is that
correct my real name is Eddie
yeah
bro that's my real name yeah uh the
point that you mentioned it's very
interesting very true however bro I
think we need to when we look at the
Dynamics between the process of Salem
and his wives what kind of a man was he
and what kind of a woman was the
prophet's wives very important now if I
come home and my wife says there's no
food
I'm not going to be that what I'm saying
we need to look at the Dynamics of its
firstly because now if I'm coming home
to a rebellious woman
and a woman who's rebellious and I'm
coming home and she doesn't care that I
I like about me being fit she does not
care I'm going out to provide a work
the least I would expect is that some
kind of food is there now when the
process comes back and actually says
that she knows who Aisha is
she knows his wife she knows that when
she says there's no food it's not of
maliciousness it's not because of
something else it's because when you
know akilo we are friends and we are
partners when our partner comes like if
I come home and my wife says there's no
food I know my wife I know may Allah
bless her what kind of an amazing woman
she is to me I know she's not saying no
food for you she's basically saying
and if she says there is no food what
would I assume I know my wife you know
what must be a tyranteed number two
maybe she forgot number three maybe she
overslept I give those good assumptions
why because of who she is now if you are
married to somebody and you know what
kind of a person she is and she's a kind
of rebellious toxic person let's say
argument say yeah when she says no food
you know what that means and you know
your response not going to be that okay
no problem
so I think when you mention that it's
very important and key the relationship
Dynamics are very important because the
prophet knows how Aisha is so that's why
the response is like that I'm trying to
say the same example when the prophet
saw Allah he's eating food with his
companions and he brings the food from
his other wife's house and I shadow sees
the food and she gets jealous she
smashes the plate roll imagine you're
chilling with your boys and your wife
smashes the plate yeah are you mad yeah
what are you like she's finished unless
you're like a job said you're finished
yeah literally you're finished but did
the prophet shout swear hit her all the
prophet saws said is
companions companies your mother's upset
that's it
because you know that at that moment it
was jealousy because you know it's not
from a malicious place
I'm trying to say you know your wife and
if you know your husband when they say
no you're like okay there's trust you
know how we have taught in Allah there's
certain things happen in my life where
I'm like
I mean why would all not do that to me
like Richard I'm like why would that's
that's so painful and so hurtful
but you know when you have tawakul you
know you know what
I'm gonna find that one day why I did
that and that they did come like a
marriage documentary and I was like you
know what oh Allah
I'm getting Goosebumps when I say this
from I said thank you for doing that you
saved me from the biggest disaster it's
literally me jumping in the fire and you
took me out and I didn't see it and I
said oh Allah thank you so much for
doing that I hated every second of it I
even became a little rebellious forgive
me and wallahi this is why it's so
important having trust
with your Lord but also having trust
with your friends if your friend in a
fight comes into something berserk like
I don't know grabs you and takes you and
you think what are you doing buff like
and you're and then you're like bro you
know that guy had a knife and you're
like okay but if you know your friend
you'll be like you know what there's a
reason he's doing this so I think the
Dynamics are very important between
relationships understand okay why is she
saying that so I think just to other I
don't know sorry to go in a bit sorry no
no you're good bro so with that being
said I have a question I have a question
is the dynamic what happened bro
I said are you going to ask me whether
my documentary's coming out again no no
you already answered them bro you
already answered that
but I'm saying if if we're talking about
the Dynamics the Dynamics are so
important then why is it that there are
so many brothers out here getting the
Dynamics so twisted and they're so
deluded they're not really here they're
not basing like everything in their
perception everything in reality they
have this like this almost this like La
La Land like they have this like thing
in their head it's like now this is what
it's supposed to be and what they're
experiencing is it might be completely
out of tune with what they're thinking
in the head but it's like no no it has
to be this way so what do you think in
your opinion why there's so many
brothers that do think this way that
aren't actually in reality they just
they're kind of delusional for like a
better words
so can you give me something specific
like when you mean that when you say and
then when you say specifically Brothers
um what do you mean by that so okay you
said you said that Dynamic and you gave
the example of the Prophet Muhammad and
the Aisha his wife really loved one now
you said how what kind of a man he was
and what kind of a woman she was yeah
yeah so now we're talking about
relationships and in today's day you
have let's say a brother and a sister
they get together
um obviously you know the brother is not
going to be anywhere near what the
prophet Muhammad so Allah was yeah no is
the sister going to be like Aisha but we
can strive to be this we can strive to
be our best yeah now with that being
said men you know Brothers unfortunately
don't get into a marriage and they will
expect certain things but they won't
fully understand the woman nor will the
dynamic be fully there you know maybe
they might provide maybe they might do
all these things but then when it comes
to them being with their wives they're
not fully present with their wives they
don't they're not fulfilling all of the
rights
of the way if you get what I'm saying
here okay from what I understand
um I think this is a phenomena that is
happening and I'm not going to deny it
that it does happen from the brother's
side
but I think we also need to be fair here
also a lot of sisters are in this
this La La Land as well I'll say
um and and we're seeing this
increasingly uh from the sister side as
well I'm not trying to shift it like we
know certain things you know men do Etc
and there are main copies and certain
stuff men do but the thing is I think it
can be a lack of experience because at
the end of the day people that you talk
to is very important and that's why a
lot of times we have false perceptions
when it comes to marriage and a lot of
times for example men have that as well
when it comes to for example oh these
are my rights this this is my right this
my right Etc the point that comes back
to is this yeah is that men well men
want traditional women
yep
um but the thing is for example it is
hard to find that so what's happening is
there's a great conflict happening
between that because they want a
traditional woman who'll be a mother who
be a carer he'll be a wife a companion
that they can come home to I'm thinking
these expectations they have maybe it's
simple like if a man says you know what
I'm the provider I would be happy if I
come home to a hot meal I mean like like
if you think about it is he asking for
something great let's think about it to
have a hot meal like for example if a
man is out there being the protector yes
and the maintainer okay I feel sometimes
that sisters they don't truly
acknowledge that they feel like okay you
know you have to do that okay that's
fine a man accepts that responsibility
and says you know what I have to do that
and it's not easy and I do do that but
when they come home for a man it's like
you know the way we are we like to be
appreciated is not necessarily by words
Woman They likely be heard like you know
you're beautiful you know you're amazing
okay like like these the kind of things
I'm trying to say they love it like
sometimes I look at my wife she's you
know sometimes she drives the government
when I'm doing something I ensure that
she drives the car and I just look at
her sometimes and I go you know what you
know you're so beautiful and then I can
see foreign
but for a man we don't work like that we
like to be given that um way of saying
thank you or nice words via action so
when I when a man comes home and he's
like you know what my wife cooked
she loves me she must like she cares
about me so instead of coming and saying
I love you I care about you men like to
be more
teeth in different ways
yeah no no go on I was just gonna say
bro they remind me of this I was talking
to my wife the other day and we're just
talking about you know
relationship Dynamics and masculinity
and femininity and she said something
very profound she's like a lot of the
women that she talks to nowadays she she
explains to them that you know you're
talking to your man in a way that you
shouldn't be and men like to feel like a
man and it does what you were saying
that it's not just what you say to a man
but it's how you say it and and how it
makes them feel you know
exactly this is very important role and
today what we're seeing bro like it's
again like I'm I want people to really
understand this I don't mean it in a way
I'm just trying to find the balance I'm
speaking to a lot of people I'm looking
at a lot of studies Etc a lot of men are
being oppressed a lot of men are being
oppressed greatly greatly bro now this
doesn't mean that because men have been
oppressed women are not being oppressed
I'm not saying that we know that you
know when it comes to you know domestic
abuse you know statistics show that both
are as violent as each other by the way
men and women are advised that it's just
men have more lethal Force that's why we
look at certain stats women tend to
attempt suicide men
um kind of use um end up dying in the
pursuit like someone can commit suicide
and not die but men use more you for
lethal Force that's what they end up
being one of those you know they they
take their life so the thing is we need
to answer for a man even if a man is
wrong and it depends what wrong gets
yeah when I say wrong I'm not talking
about something extreme like oh he came
and punched you in the face not talking
about that please yeah if he even if a
man is wrong so a man does something
wrong to his wife argument say upset sir
something she gets upset now if a woman
acts in a way where she starts going she
moves like a man like what how do you do
that to me stop trying
oh hold on a second man hold on a second
to me I'll be honest with you
if my wife if I would say something to
my wife yeah and there's been times
where I've said something of her I
didn't mean to
but her reaction was like her femininity
with the way she deals with it makes me
laugh I'm not I'm like oh then I said
actually I was wrong here I would come
and buy your flowers and I'll say you
know what forgive me yeah
and then
the fact that her attitude when I was
wrong and I may have said something that
upset her the fact that she dealt with
it in a feminine way made me more
attracted to her
and I looked at and I thought of the
comparison and I thought wife she's
lashed out and said get the hell out of
the house or she grabbed a bottle and
threw at me and I dodged it and she was
trying to come at me physically probably
like once like this I wanted to marry a
man I mean a woman this is this would be
like a man so the thing is I'd be like I
didn't sign up for this so from my point
of view I'm like
that little argument number one
it's it was okay should not be done but
the way you moved about it you put my
big question mark on on your head so I
think it's very important the way we
communicate and we need to understand
this vice versa works with women the way
and that's why it's so important when we
talk about gender roles we are different
beings we cannot treat the the greatest
Injustice is to treat
on equal things equally oh no no the
greatest inequality is to treat
unequal things equally
and that's what we're doing broth and
this is where we're trying to fit in
like no we're the same we are not the
same we are not the same it's not
reality
I think a lot of these modern women's
movements too
um yes the things that they propagate to
even even if you look at our pill for
for men these movements are very selfish
towards the gender that they are
prioritizing to be their Niche you know
what I mean and and what I see in a lot
of these women's movements today too is
they have this false notion that men and
women are the same and because of that
women are literally conditioned to
behave in a way that they think oh a man
should think the way we think why does
he not see things the way I see it why
is he not this way we're not the same
bro just like you said Allah has created
us very unequally you know we're still
in the eyes of Allah in terms of you
know value but it's not the same bro
we're not the same we are not the same
bro it's a big fat lie and this is the
issue and this has been brought like
even Muslim women Affair for this trap
you know and that's the reason why when
I released inshallah my marriage
documentary bro I'm taking a step away
from Tower of it meaning my what I
produce now is like 80 to 90 dollar
material I mean 80 we have current
affairs Etc I'm trying to reduce that
because sometimes there's a lot of great
blobs and that will handle that I'm not
that I'm going to leave it handle this
it's a part of me but I'm concentrating
heavily on the family unit marriage and
because you know why but there's an
outright attack on the family unit if
the households are under attack bro we
need the defense mechanism and that's
what happened there's a lot of brothers
out there Gabriel Romani Etc these are
and and this is the name of Robertson
and many other individuals who are there
because we need to preserve the family
unit bro it's a full out under attack
and if that's under attack bro things
are going to crumble like one scholar
said women give women are they make up
half the population of Earth and they
give birth to the other half bro they
are the backbone of this ummah we need
them we need our sisters we need our
sisters to be on point also our brothers
as well but sisters play they're the
ones who nurture the Next Generation bro
so we need to dedicate our time and I'm
personally brought I'm taking that time
to pursue to the whatever I've got my
life is left to pursue to do that role
because I know how important it is to
have a good partner and in the document
I mentioned that bro marrying the wrong
person can kill you
it will come to that it can kill you
slowly not instantly instantly okay it
happened it will kill you slowly trust
me so the thing is here it's very
important for us to understand that and
that's the reason why when it comes to
you let's touch upon an issue when it
comes to the issue of polygamy is that
when I'm having a job done a video
the reason why women for example when it
comes this very hurtful thing is it's
very hurtful obviously for your husband
to go get married again Etc
but the point is this woman look at it
from this point of view they say the
following because we know women are
monogamous by Nature they want one king
one man simple as that that's in their
blood yeah obviously there's exceptions
to the rule but exceptions don't make
the rule so now the thing is
um they they they they are monogamous by
nature and that's what they are looking
for so when they love a a man they're
thinking in their head I love him
and if I ever was to fall out of love
with him I would end the relationship
and move on with someone else correct
okay now what they're doing is then this
is the difference between men and women
they look at you when their husband gets
a second wife what's going through their
head
if I was to do that I would only do it
once I've fallen out of love with my
husband correct therefore he doesn't
love me anymore Ah that's the reason why
he wants a second wife and we're like uh
not really that's not the case at all
because if that's the case most of the
times men who have multiple wives and by
the way this phenomena is not a Muslim
issue not Muslim and practice this Islam
is just set protocols to protect the
other co-wives so you don't amend or
abusing abuse and abuse them so when a
man does that most of the times when he
gets married the mad if things go peshi
he usually returns back to the first
wife but if he didn't have the first
wife why is he returned back to the
first wife so the Dynamics in our head
we a man if you go to a man he would he
will never say to you I got a second
wife because I felt like fell out of
love my wife I have no problem with my
wife I love the tibits she is the most
amazing woman it has nothing to do with
that but do you see how a woman looks at
it she's looking from her point of view
that is just one aspect of how we are
different
[Music]
um
bro I've had so many discussions with
men too it's it's the ways a lot of
sisters move is they project how they
their world view and and their frame of
of perspective into how a man thinks and
they think that the Neo the intention is
is why they would have done it and
there's so many things I can talk about
too but my next question to you is what
do you say to these types of women that
are kind of like okay you know what if
you're saying that if you're gonna
provide you're gonna protect then I'm
gonna you know you want me to make food
and all this type of stuff you want me
to cook you want me to clean whatever
but what about the women that say okay
you know what I would rather want you to
do some of the household stuff and and
and I'm gonna work too you know like
like we'll go 50 50 on everything I'm
gonna I'm gonna die on that Hill what do
you say to those types of women no
problem this is this is once again I
think it would come from a place of
being maybe disingenuous because let's
be honest there was a study done
actually about the book here yeah uh I
won't show the cover because it's
the school girls uh yeah but it's still
it's James truly yeah okay it's called
the miseducational woman yeah so there
you go read read this book very
interesting I was reading it today as
well yeah there was a study done over 30
years from the 1970s I think to 19
um 2000 something on this line they it
they they ask questions in America and
uh UK to a hundred thousand participants
they found out that
people are less happier specifically
women
and when you read it wrong you know what
it says woman a lot of women do not want
to vote they do not want to work they
don't want to work they want to be they
said we would prefer to be at home so
for somebody to say that it's I would
say it stems from a little argument that
happened with a husband and I'm trying
to prove a point yeah I'll go work and
okay no problem you go work but the
thing is what's going to happen is
there's going to be a couple of issues
because at the end of the day in a man's
nature he wants to be the protector and
provider when he comes and says to you
he he would like he will appreciate and
I think it's important for us Brothers
to deliver our message in a good way one
thing Andrew taste means a lot of facts
there's a lot of things I disagree with
him he speaks on facts but I believe him
and his delivery is terrible
said the truth is hard for people don't
make it harder with your Bad Manners
it's already hard don't make it hard
with your Bad Manners bro so the thing
is agitate his delivery was rubbish the
way he referred to women Etc even if I
was a woman and he was speaking facts
I'll tell him I'm not taking anything
you say everything you say are from in
the world what kind of delivery is that
bro it's referring to me as a h-o-e and
I'll get the hell out of you I'm not
gonna take nothing you say so his
delivery is rubbish so as men we need to
our speech delivery has to be very very
important because women are emotional
beings okay I don't care if there's any
feminist no we're not issue one this
studies that show it you know so the
thing is here if a husband says to his
wife I prefer well just to cook meal if
I can come home for work I want a long
out milk I would like some respect like
and also the man is the head of the
house this is mentioned in the bible
yes the man is there has to be one need
in the house simple as that now me being
a leader in my house doesn't undermine
nothing you know actually my wife
someone sometimes says to me I like the
fact that you say you know what today
we're going to go and do this this is
the plan the whole day now if my wife
comes and says Ali instead of calling
you should we go here I'll go actually
no yes
I'm not gonna shut up how dare you say
that I'm the leader how dare you let me
let me uh let me get my stick and beat
you
come on if a man conveys what he wants
some basic standard things for you to
then turn around and say oh if you
expect that then I'm gonna go work this
is kind of rebellion because what did he
ask you if you ask you in a polite
manner simple things that he likes and
now you're like well if that's the case
I'm going to work why do you need to
mention that because he has no problem
working okay when a man comes and says
you know what I've worked long hours and
you know I've come home there's no like
there's no food you know I would have
appreciated if the woman then starts
saying oh let me go and work she's I
think what she's trying to say is the
following
are you telling me maybe it's the
delivery of the brother man maybe for
the husband are you it's maybe to her it
comes as if he's complaining about
working so she's saying well if that's
the case then I'll work it might be that
let's be let's be understandable here
yeah if it's that then just communicate
better and say no look I have no problem
working I'm not complaining about
working it's hard but it's a part of my
duty I love doing it it's just I
appreciate you know because it's hard I
came from work and I just want a hot
meal you know I think communication is
very important so if we look between the
you know the the lines I think it's
important but if a woman insists of that
it's not going to work I was watching I
came across a YouTube recommendation
um some says hijabi sister and I don't
want to mention and make it specific
and they would there was a vlog of her
and her husband and they were getting it
um I don't again specifics because
people were already talking about them
so they went to get something some kind
of cosmetic done yeah from what I
gathered from the videos because I
watched this stuff just to understand
the Dynamics yeah it's as if she is the
breadwinner she had her own office with
her name in the back yeah it's as if she
is the breadwinner and I thought to
myself oh
may Allah firstly I said mashallah
like to her marriage yeah not the
Dynamics that's going on and may Allah
preserve and I see this may Allah
preserve their marriage well I don't
want anyone to go through divorce but I
was like if that is the case I do not
know how much longer his husband would
be living like that bro if your wife is
paying for the tickets and the bill and
the petrol and the rent and
I don't know bro I it's not gonna work
it's not gonna work it's gonna explode
somewhere because a mere argument just
will trick and she'll be like you know
what who paid for that holiday we went
last week who paid for who pay for this
bro that's gonna destroy man it's like
you punching him in the face bang bang
bang right hook uppercut a headbutt yeah
and what you think is he's going to be
messed up he's going to be like you know
what
forget this he will say forget this and
this is the issue we are facing gender
roles
again I could be married to a let's see
if my woman my wife was a
multi-millionaire
it's it's very hard you need to be very
careful because those kind of women I'll
be honest they
tend to date across and up woman yeah
they would want someone on that
cardboard which I'm trying to say but
even if I was I'll tell her
that's your money but I pay for the rent
in this house I pay for the shopping in
this house I pay for I am going to
that's mine I want to do that you're
rich my wealthy family that's well and
good if you decide and say you know what
I want to treat us okay no problem it's
all right you want to treat us okay
that's fine but to a certain level why
we need to understand the Dynamics as a
man I don't want to be filled felt as if
I'm a no one did you get what I'm trying
to say men want to feel they are the
protectors and maintainers so we need to
understand that it meant if we don't
you're gonna have clashes you're gonna
Clash this is the way I need to
acknowledge if I go to my wife and be
like I've decided to not work anymore
you're going to work and provide I'm
going to stay at home
to her she might be like okay yeah I
don't mind doing that but deep down bro
she's gonna be like what kind of a guy
is this one look I'm sitting at home
doing nothing I'll be honest bro you can
be even open enough to fit now she might
see a guy look at this guy look how he's
working and providing bro women are wide
in a certain way they will start to
disrespect you and think look at this
guy sitting at home looking after the
kids bro these things
and I mentioned this I'll be honest bro
I I hear stories
these things even lead to disloyalty bro
and sometimes I blame the men and I ask
the brother okay what went wrong this is
what happened oh oh yeah I don't want to
get into specifically I don't want
anyone but what I'm saying is though
that when I look at these things bro
sometimes I blame a man a couple you
know it's your fault the way you've been
moving and acting
that's the reason she went and maybe did
that and I'm not trying to say because I
know sometimes females don't like
accountability and blame it but
sometimes it's a man's fault bro there's
certain boundaries there's certain
things you need to make clear if you
don't make that
things will turn a bit pear-shaped
this see this this is bring this brings
me to one of the comments that I wanted
to put up here sister Khadijah wrote my
dad has three wives he lives in Somalia
or I don't know how he did it but that's
the case he's a good husband to my mom
that's all that matters um about others
too now I wanted to touch on this too
because alhamdulillah seems like she has
she has a good she has it the way but
Netflix the media they're always hyper
impose these rare anomalies where it's
like a man is not just and then it's
like the girl's like oh this is how my
dad was you never give me time you never
give he gave the other cool wife more
time and then they'll like really blow
that out of proportion like Netflix and
the media to make it look like poly
doesn't work when in reality the way
Allah has ordained it to work if we
really try to stick to the Sunnah and to
the Deen then it's phenomenal bro
again like you know that sister
mentioned something about you know his
her dad's got three wives Etc
um free was Etc look at the end of the
day look yeah
if a sister came to me and I said this a
lot yeah if her sister came to me and
said my husband got a second wife and
I'm thinking of divorcing him yeah I'll
ask some very basic questions I'll say
look sister firstly marital issues I
wouldn't advise anyone to get involved
it's very messy but if she's saying
getting a divorce you know what I'll say
to her I'll say sister simple questions
does he pray okay is he got fear okay is
he good to you holistically good
provides protects kind loving okay good
good okay all right he's good
holistically he's a good guy okay is he
someone that he get you Etc no okay good
verbally like no okay
you've got kids okay I'll tell her
sister do not divorce this man
do not divorce this man forget your
friends and most of the times bro it's
peer pressure when they go to their
friends oh my gosh did he really do that
to you and it's the same friend speaking
as if her man is not polygamous by
nature and maybe doing it in different
ways yeah and what happens is both
society makes it worse okay and believe
me bro I look this discussion I have
with my wife okay I ask my I say it's my
wife I go imagine I went and got married
again let's have a high professional
sorry okay I went and got married again
okay
I come and tell you I'll tell you
straight up you obviously have a moment
of you being you're upset you go to your
family or your friends and your friends
say the following or your mom and dad
says the following you know what Ali in
totality is he good to you yes he is you
love him yes you love each other good he
praise God God fear and good okay
inshallah I am yeah and all these
factors okay
um you know what be patient he's a good
guy
I asked specifically I said how would
that help your decision-making process
she said well I will go to my family and
friends with a burden on my shoulder but
that would make me feel a bit better
I'll feel a bit better I said now let's
reverse it let's suppose you go to your
family and your friends and they were
like what how dare he does that are you
gonna talk what how would you because
they would have add up to my burden and
I was like that's very interesting
you know Aki I was social surroundings
and people around us have a massive
impact on us a massive impact bro if you
have bad in-laws yeah well they can
destroy your marriage they can destroy
your marriage both simple words of
advice can finish your marriage off
so what I'm saying is the following
wrong that
these factors play a role so if he is
good to his wife and he does that yes I
understand it's painful it's hurtful but
he doesn't do it no man wakes up and
says I'm going to make my life wife's
life hell I'm going to be malicious and
no man does that so what I'm saying is
sisters don't end your marriage and like
somebody says was saying over this you
know why because look the issue of
polygamy is not going to leave you you
know like the second law of
Thermodynamics yeah you're thinking what
is that what are you talking about
brother you guys got some thermodynamics
the second law of Thermodynamics is that
energy cannot be created or destroyed so
you know when I have a piece of paper
and I burn it it doesn't disappear the
energy forms into something else right
right
okay to see if you guys acknowledge it
so this is energy it's just changing to
a different form okay so what I'm trying
to see is for a man yeah and I ask you
this as well yeah brothers would you say
you guys are polygamous by Nature I know
your wife's gonna be watching this but
you know would you say you are
I mean I think I think honestly I think
it's just hardwired into men yeah it's
literally it's it's we can choose we
could choose not to be but it's
hardwired we could choose not to be but
it's it's an innate proclivity it's our
nature bro what do you mean by you can
choose not to be what do you mean by
that
you can make the decision to stay
monogamous it's a decision no no but is
it a decision you would like or not like
uh that's that's
the difference
[Music]
bro we application
we are playing this by Nature bro if we
had the option if I ask you a question
you don't need to answer if ask your
question that if your wives were totally
okay brother zero consequences zero
minus minus ten yeah nothing you guys
will go get second lives all day every
day and I can see this problem with the
hat hold up hold up let me just say one
thing
this is legit though I think it's legit
because
if you put the scenario now you gotta
like ask the question okay are you good
financially
um can you handle it mentally because
bro like you you know how much a woman
takes up bro I was literally a mental
space I literally I literally told my
wife this yesterday and it was it was a
joke right but it still holds true you
know like lately I've been working like
about eight to ten hours bro sitting in
the office when I finally see her it's
like early and then I also have like
other things to do in that time I'm just
personally not managing my time the way
I should be and then I'll start telling
you I was like oh this is me with like
one wife yeah imagine the people that
are for wiserable imagine the time
management the amount of like discipline
that they need like be equal and try to
be their best like it's nuts bro
no it is but what I'm saying is this yet
at the end of the day there are certain
factors that you if you have in place it
makes certain matters easier okay
um but what I'm saying is that we can
all accept that if certain conditions
are in place that we are polygamous by
nature and we would explore those
chances we would it changes from Men to
Men from different age groups of course
you know but that's a different story
but what I'm seeing is this is how we
are programmed so the reason why I would
tell that sister not to get a divorce is
because you're not running away from the
problem every man if you're going to
marry a man unless the sister says you
know I'm moving a bit a different way
I'm going to marry a woman that will be
a lot
um but if you're going to marry a man
the problem is still there it's going to
come in a different form it's either
he's going to do it in a hidden way Etc
so what I'm saying is to the sister I
would say don't divorce him stay with
him he's a good man in totality and be
patient with it now Islam is giving it
off we're not Jews Judaism Judaism you
can't get it it's called The get if you
don't if your husband doesn't give it
you are not getting divorce you marry
them forever and
so you have those rights but what I
would say is you're better off and even
statistically showing in a children that
are raised in a single household by
single mothers all the statistics are
mad very very mad and we're not blaming
the mothers we're just saying obviously
mothers are the carers that's what show
that so this is another topic but what
I'm just seeing in a nutshell we need to
understand the gender roles once we
figure out that these for example men
are like this why can't I talk about it
so much these days because I'm trying to
make sisters understand this is not
coming from a malicious place no man
wakes up and says I want to hurt my wife
when women clock the gender the how we
are programmed and how we work things
will be much much more better bro once
we understand our sisters it's the same
goes with us once we understand how they
operate how they work that's why some
brothers
she didn't mean it bro if a woman comes
and says
and give a time give us some space she's
gonna come and tell you look I look I
didn't mean it but Brothers what they do
they get angry bro the word very very
careful bro talaq is my right yeah
if I had to argue with my wife and she
said to me I want to get well so you
know what I'm happy with you I don't
want to divorce you if you're not happy
with me you can get caught up you wonder
oh you don't want it okay that's fine I
don't wanna I don't divorce you so it's
we need to be very clever and understand
the genders we need to understand the
females as well we have this the biggest
problem we're having as well we are not
understanding them and they are not
understanding us and that's the reason
why that's clash Clash Clash and that's
one of the reasons inshallah the future
projects I'm working on will inshallah
aim inshallah too
make individual well genders to
understand each other bro I think if we
understand each other then we'll be like
okay you know it's like it's like an
islamophobe looking at Muslims these
terrorists but the moment they
understand that oh my gosh I didn't know
about that it's the same with us we're
like oh my gosh like to your wife I
didn't know you fought like that oh I
did what I'm trying to say once it sinks
in your life okay it's not that deep
yeah I got no problem I get that um man
it's it sucks that the time is up bro
because I'd love to continue this we got
two questions though that I want you to
answer real quick um but inshallah even
in the next few weeks bro in October we
can we can hit another stream inshallah
um continue this um so I want to know
your thoughts on this so
the common says can Ali explain why RP
is kofor or Haram according to him I
don't know if you've ever mentioned that
well red pill that it's that is kufur or
Haram
can I explain why red pill oh sorry oh
do you say RP yeah yeah I mean it's all
good bro
I've never said that
um I I haven't I don't remember saying
this Haram or something I don't remember
that well I know it's that it's against
the Sunnah it's as simple as that
feminism RP whatever you want to call it
whatever it may be it's look that's not
our world view and this is the issue
that we are facing we are taking our
uncle over the knuckle our logic when I
say logic obviously we need our logic
but what I'm saying is we are taking our
thought process and what we think to be
logical based on our uh moral compasses
are changing every two seconds
this is what Iblis fell into if you
understand how Iblis fell into the story
of Adam and Iblis is your key to success
he believes said Adam I am better than
him
can you imagine his Lord is in his Lord
is there and he is saying
I am better than him and Allah because
you misguided me can you imagine he says
Allah and you are wrong you are telling
me to do something like logically I'm
made of fire he's made that play I'm
better than him so you now look at the
the the the crazy well how stupid you
have to be bro Allah tell you to do
something but logically you're like that
doesn't go with my logic you're telling
me to bow down to something
um better than him that's that's your
mistake he is ascribing a mistake to
Allah
this is the issue that we have today we
think we know I know this that makes
sense feminism uh RP this stuff no
anytime you try to follow your man-made
woman-made laws you are going to suffer
that's the reason why we have sisters a
pandemic of sisters and brothers are
traveling abroad to get married yeah
there's no traditional woman if they're
saying and same with our system I say
sisters who are reaching their 30s
career woman career ladies yeah
regretful regretful less chances of
having a child less chance of finding
somebody their standards are dropping
and what was it career a man doesn't
care about a career if my wife one life
my wife was a Dustbin collector and if I
saw her well I'll have no problem Marina
I have no problem I don't care Korea bro
I don't care what she does for a woman
and it goes back to what they look at us
how how they perceive us they think we
perceive them they think I don't care
about your career after your career
Manchester they will studies that show a
woman who has a career job instead of
high creature tends to end relationships
like something along those lines yeah we
don't care about your career we don't
care how much you earn it means nothing
to us and you know what if you do it's
going to actually jeopardize our
marriage so what does it go back to what
Allah told us if we obey by that we will
be happy if you don't want to look for
Alternatives and feminism and RP you are
going to suffer you're going to hit the
wall and when you hit that wall just
realize that Allah is Messenger what
they said was true boom you heard it
here first I mean last question from
Miracle writes what if the wife fears
that she'll be undutiful in marriage due
to the man having another wife out of
envy and jealousy and doesn't want to
disobey Allah
to be honest
look at the end of the day look like I
said Islam has given a right to divorce
if a woman feels that she's going to be
and look at the end of the day look
there was a child was telling me this I
don't know who I don't think it was even
I can't remember he said one of the um
Scholars when the you know when the
prophet's wife got angry and upset with
him yeah some of the scholars said that
this is not even caused as a sin on
their behalf
because of just I can't I'm trying to
reiterate about trying to remember but
basically in a nutshell
is it disobedience in the sense where
they got upset and angry when the
prophet's wife smashed the plate was
that a sin was that what was that so
some Scholars have a discussion on this
so we cannot say per se if if a man has
a second wife it comes home his wife
hasn't cooked Etc there's certain things
that he's gonna have to put up with if
he's gonna done that there's certain
things but it doesn't work like that if
you if you are not ready to deal with
what's going to come after don't get
involved simple as that but this doesn't
mean a wife now goes on purpose and
causes them and takes the kids away no
no no no no that's a whole different
oppression to taking the kids away and
threatening and this that Etc you are
you are oppressing and you it's in the
sight of Allah you're in trouble however
if you have moments where you're angry
upset crying shouting
Etc a man has to put up with it he has
to put up with it he he needs to
understand her emotions he needs a
problem if he can't don't get involved
in it but sisters doesn't mean that you
cross the boundaries and you start doing
some real mad stuff you know
um yeah that's that's why I would say
personally
sorry man I know bro you got anything
else to say before you wrap this up
man there's a question I want to ask but
I'm gonna leave it for the next one man
because
I will answer on the next one okay okay
okay
so we know how we were talking about all
this stuff and you were mentioning
polygamy and and how it's made of Nature
and all this
I heard this uh a discounted argument by
many many sisters and and also many
brothers as well and I've thought about
it myself I just I like to reflect on
these things and just kind of like
uh just Pawn to see like what comes up
and ask but you have the example of the
Prophet Muhammad
before he was polygamous
he was monogamous and
the argument that's being made many
times is like oh well if you have like a
woman like khalijah
there's no need
so it's like in your in your uh research
because I'm sure you've looked into it
as well and like you probably talked
about it like what what has come up for
this because I'm sure many many people
out there are interested in that
but again we can leave this for the next
one because
you mean it's the next show I'll be
answering it yeah bro Ali Ali when are
you free next you free next week
um yeah I should be I should be we could
do we could do if you're free same time
same place same link inshallah guys
um
yeah and let us let us know what you
guys think in the in the description on
or in the comments you know let us know
what you guys thought about the stream
if you want you know any anything else
specifically answered or not maybe next
time we'll we'll plan in a way where I
I'll leave like an hour extra after the
end time just so you know anything
happens we can we can go a little bit
over time inshallah and Rami can be
there too um and brother Ali it was a
pleasure having you may Allah bless you
for your work and your time and for
buttock on your work and when the
marriage documentary comes through give
us like a pre-screening all right we'll
give you our thoughts and inshallah I'll
send you the trailer yeah sounds good
though all right